when you look at classic planets from
science fiction one that really stands
out is Hoth the icy world from Empire
Strikes Back you want to find an
analogue to Hoth I'd say probably the
best one that we know right now is in
our own solar system it's the moon
Enceladus of Saturn which is this you
know pristine white icy ball that has
these fantastic geysers of ice that kind
of spray out into space now until this
way less hospitable than Hoth was but
you know if you're looking for that kind
of like icy world that would certainly
be an option
no Wampus though in Star Trek
one of the classic planetary systems is
the homeworld of the Romulans which is
actually a double planet system Romulus
and Remus now the idea of two planets
that are orbiting one another isn't just
science fiction so if you take a look
out at the very outer reaches of our
solar system you get to the dwarf planet
Pluto and its moon Charon if you watch
the two of them orbiting you actually
find that the two objects orbit around a
mutual point in space that would
actually categorize it as a as a dual
planet system so in the movie alien the
planet lv-426 in a lot of ways is gonna
be much more typical of exoplanets that
we find it's a very hostile environment
you know it does have an atmosphere its
rocky its terrestrial in a way that is
what exoplanets really are trying to
find anything that seems even remotely
habitable is a very very rare thing but
you can't go anywhere in this we
actually had a press release come up
finding evidence of an asteroid belt in
the system known as Epsilon Eridani now
as big Babylon 5 fans when we were
getting a chance to illustrate this the
system is kind of exciting it's like
maybe we could put in a little reference
to it so hidden way down in the corner
was this very subtle hint of a
silhouette of a shadow vessel the bad
guys from Babylon 5 hidden down to the
nebula once in a very rare a while it's
it's fun to kind of work in some kind of
a thematic aliy appropriate reference
into a piece of art
when I was a kid at one of my thrills
was the idea of being a special-effects
artist and the fact that I actually am
doing visual effects for NASA is pretty
darn awesome